we are going to begin with the growing
tensions over taking off our masks or
not cdc director rachelle wolinski says
we are not there yet and the agency
still recommends that americans should
wear masks in public indoor spaces
however more states are dropping their
mass mandates new york massachusetts
rhode island and illinois are the latest
to do so five other states rolled back
their rules in just the past few days
nevada could soon follow suit nationwide
here's the picture seven-day average for
new cobot cases around 230 000. yes that
is far lower than it was a month ago but
it is still considered high transmission
according to the cdc well lalangi is
following all this for us mola good
morning to you
good morning you know just two months
ago new york city's greenwich village
neighborhood here had one of the highest
coveted rates in the country but as
cases have plummeted and more americans
grow exhausted with the pandemic lifting
some of these mass mandates has been
welcomed by many with a sigh of relief
more and more parents across the country
in places where mass mandates remain in
effect in schools are arguing now is the
time to finally take those masks off
we're out here now to get the masks off
i'm angry i'm i think it's time in
illinois school boards are feeling the
heat from angry parents fed up with
masking in schools
i'm deeply concerned about the impact
that wearing masks eight plus hours a
day in school has on my four-year-old 15
states and washington d.c currently have
k-12 mask mandates in place six have
announced they'll ease that restriction
in the coming weeks it's a temporary
period of uncertainty joseph allen is a
public health researcher from harvard
we're on the back end of a wave we
should take advantage of this time pull
back controls we should absolutely
continue to monitor the trends meanwhile
the cdc says it's working on updating
mass guidance but that now is not the
time to let up we continue to recommend
masking in areas of high and substantial
transmission
that's much of the country right now in
public indoor settings for new york
which has twice been the epicenter of
covet cases lifting mask mandates in
most public settings marks a major step
new yorkers this is what we've waiting
for tremendous progress after two
long years
and we're not done but this is trending
in a very very good
direction and that is why we are now
approaching a new phase in this pandemic
well here in new york school mask
mandates remain in place in part because
only 39 percent of 5 to 17 year olds are
fully vaccinated dana
all right mola thank you